when I think about who I was as a person
before I came out a lot of it was me
trying to be this person that I knew
that I wasn't I think the most important
word that jumps out at me is closed off
but I think I was trying to hide so much
I remember thinking this was the worst
thing that could have happened to me
and that God hated me or something like
that and I remember going to church and
being like oh my god I don't know what's
wrong with me but I know I'm not normal
please help me out I never really opened
up to anyone I had a really hard time
pretty much just kept like a wall
between me even my closest friends like
if we were ever having a conversation
about being gay I would always like kind
of overreact and be like oh no that's
gross some people like would absolutely
not think anything about me in the job
that I had I like worked in kind of a
corporate world and I like didn't feel
comfortable sharing my sexual identity
with people that I worked with I would
like wear like cute leather flats and
like skirts and like I hated it it was
what I thought I needed to do to survive
I loved things like dance and figure
skating and I could speak the language
and I could play the game as far as how
to present myself physically with
clothes and makeup and hair little
things would trigger me back then to
feel really uncomfortable and really
like in my head for instance I remember
like freshman year if I was sitting
eating lunch with a group of girls I
would feel insecure because I would feel
like guys are looking at me thinking oh
look at that guy he's [ __ ] gay I was
very shy I was very reserved I didn't I
didn't like opening up to people I
always felt like I couldn't be much
herself like I feel fine that I'm like
passing and like people aren't you know
saying stuff about me but on the inside
I just I would feel crushed a few years
before I came out I started dating a
woman and like in a very committed
relationship before anybody really knew
sometimes it felt like we were playing
pretend or that you know we couldn't
hold hands in public or we couldn't just
be like oh let me tell my friend about
my girlfriend because it's this really
cool and exciting thing that's happening
my life and not being able to do that
for years just because I was afraid of
what was gonna happen was so hard it
took a lot to convince myself that you
know I wasn't gonna go to hell I had to
do a lot of work around those years
between
and 2021 to really find out who I was on
my own outside of all of those things at
a certain point I just I couldn't keep
lying anymore I couldn't keep saying no
that's not me I had a girlfriend senior
year of high school that I very much
liked for a long time I try to hide it I
was like well if I can date a girl I
could just always like ignore the other
side of me that's like attracted to guys
because I was still confused I wasn't
even sure like what I was or what I
wanted to be me and her broke up and I
actually registered for a bunch of LGBTQ
classes in college before I came out I
wanted to have resources and information
so that people couldn't like tear me
down once I understood that I wasn't
wrong then I was like okay I'm ready to
come out and if somebody wants to
challenge me I'm gonna be like no here
is why like I know what the [ __ ] is
going on in my head my mom was the
biggest person I knew I needed to tell
to before I could like feel like I
officially came out and it could go one
of two ways either I she would see me as
her daughter and you know she would love
me and it'd be okay or like the horror
stories that you hear he was bouncing
back and forth between those two
thoughts of like I hope she's still just
like loves me before coming out to my
family in kind of the world at large was
slowly coming out and finding other
adults in the world that I could talk to
who were very accepting other out queer
people adults and finding a reference
point so I knew that no matter what I
had a future that I was gonna be okay
that even in my community even if I
didn't see those role models for those
people thriving I knew that they were
out there somewhere I just had to get
out there I finally got to a point in my
relationship where I knew we weren't
gonna get anywhere until I came out
until we both came out and it's gonna
suck and it might hurt and it might be
really detrimental to some relationships
in our lives but it's gonna be better in
the long run I was in a safe space I was
in a safe environment where I was able
to come out
and I was fortunate enough to have a mom
who listened when I come up to my mom
she took it the hardest out of everyone
but I felt like I had the resources to
help her understand what it was and what
it meant and help her through this
process because I understand that for
her is probably really hard so we were
actually on a long like a two-hour ish
car ride home you know I really need to
get this off my chest everything I
pretty much thought she would think and
say she did and in points it got even
kind of worse than what I thought it
would get it was pretty devastating like
it's the kind of stuff that you hear in
media all the time in on TV of like you
know these extreme stories about like
families kicking their kids out for
being gay or just like kind of saying
these really awful things to hear that
coming out of your own mom's mouth it
was almost a surreal experience even
though it didn't go the way I was hoping
it still helped me grow as a person and
I wouldn't trade it for the world
I can't imagine my adult life without
coming out I can't imagine if I was
still that person that I was trying to
pretend to be and I think a difference
between then versus now is that I'm my
full self now I finally get to really
figure out who I am as a person
and who I'm gonna be as a person for the
rest of my life like being gay isn't
just about who you like and who you're
attracted to and when you feel
comfortable in your clothes and in your
skin people can tell and I think you
look through life differently and you
walk through life more confidently and
for me it's really changed Who I am
people kind of would be drawn to me more
because I had those walls that I had
built and kept up for so long for people
to not kind of know anything about me
we're starting to fade and people could
see the real me and they gravitated
toward that and it made me feel good
that like people can genuinely like me
for me
the biggest thing for me has been the
acceptance that people have for you now
I'm just myself I think I'm just more
relaxed it really it really is a weight
of your shoulders we all think we have
crazy dreams but if you really believe
that you know this is something that's
genuine for you and true for you and
something that you really want you
should never stop yourself just know if
there's other people like you out there
please like find other people
that can kind of be your support system
coming out means that you're ready to
just tell the world what you are and
sometimes you're not sometimes you don't
even know what you are like it takes
years to find out what you are and it's
okay for you to say it I'm figuring it
out and we'll see and if you don't feel
like you're it's safe for you to come
out don't but do work with yourself if
you're struggling with coming out
there's no rush take your time
there's no one right way to do it it
might go really well it might not go
really well it is a moment that you
deserve to choose for yourself never let
anyone make you feel like you have to
come out when you're not ready to I hope
it's something that everyone gets to
experience and if you don't get to
experience that because you're not in a
place or a position to do so then that's
okay we still love you you are still
part of this community and you are no
less recognized for it you are no less
of a queer person for it and we are here
to celebrate who you are as a person
regardless of whether you can come out
or not there's a mountain of obstacles
but if you keep trying and you keep
talking to people and you keep reaching
out and you keep working as hard as you
possibly can you will find your spot and
you will find your safe space if it's
out there do not give up
[Music]